ils sont partout les malades du covid
partout dans les box les couloirs les
salles les tentes installées à
l'extérieur des urgences une réalité qui
glace le sang et qu’affronte jour après
jour les soignants de l'hôpital
18h entrez des équipes de nuit une
nouvelle patiente
[Musique]
Céline infirmière à gauche Nathalie
aide-soignante à droite vont la prendre
en charge la dame est âgée d'une
soixantaine d'années sont soulagement
quand elle reçoit de l'oxygène sert le
cœur
[Musique]
sur ce cahier les entrées covid de la
journée la prise en charge commence ici
pleine d'embûches vu la flûte
les patients sous l'eau pour l'instant
madame on va la laisser sous le avec
l'obus à oxygène puisqu'on a plus de
place ils sont 54 ce soir là en attente
d'être transféré dans l'un des 17
services covid ou ouverts dans les
différents hôpitaux de Martinique la
répartition se fait dans cette salle de
contrôle parmi ceux qui attendent tous
les âges et tous les profils
à la page parce que c'est assez tendu
ici
cédric est un jeune de 29 ans ses
premiers jours de covid se sont passés
sans problème puis une brutale chute
d'oxygène repérée grâce à son oxymètre
moi-même
et c'est quand on a appelé le médecin et
qu'on lui a lu les données du de la
machine que le médecin clairement a dit
ça comme tous les patients Cédric doit
passer un scanner c'est là que l'on
mesure l'atteinte au poumon et c'est
l'un des critères d'orientation
quasiment tous les patients des lésions
il y a aujourd'hui près de 340
martiniquais hospitalisées du covid
Félix Héraclide élu du marigot et l'un
d'eux il a du mal à parler mais il tient
un témoigner pour la population faites
attention à vous
respectez
cela problème prenez des actions parce
que moi j'avais pris rendez-vous je peux
le temps de l'avoir de prendre ce vaccin
lui avons mais j'espère que je me
sentirai je comptais mon vaccin
tous les jours tous les jours
[Musique]
la prise en charge commence ici et
parfois s'y arrête quand les services
sont saturés et que le patient a moins
de chance de s'en sortir
le tri c'est aussi donc
comment dire
là
non pas le laisser de côté mais
[Musique]
c'est se dire quoi que l'on fasse le
patient va décéder
parce que sur les capacités
de prise en charge seront dépassées pour
lui-même ou bien pour la structure
effectivement de ceux qui sont dans le
déni peur avec des cas dans leur rang ou
dans leur famille cette détresse c'est
aussi celle des soignants qui voient
mourir dans leur service 5 à 10
personnes par jour et qui voudraient
désespérément être compris